[Music]
all right what are some of the
most weirdest jobs out there that you
guys can think of
like just oh the dildo dipper the person
who paints the dildos
no they paint it yeah don't know the
inside is a different color like a
a kind of like a factory where you know
different people have different stations
and then the dildo like
it's finishing process one person has to
like dip the penis head in a certain
like pinkish purple
wow flesh color painted i think i
thought
i thought the material of the dildo
itself would be the color i thought it
was
if you buy a high quality one i dare you
to google dildo dipper i don't know what
you're going to find i'm still going to
look
but still well that makes me feel yeah i
kind of don't want to do this by myself
what if the peel paints in the [ __ ] oh
say that three times really fast
peel painting the [ __ ] peel paints in
the [ __ ]
when you when you think your job [ __ ]
just remember you could be maria the
dildo dipper gave it the pink head
look at that she's pouting she's oh yeah
the pink head
see whoa i don't want that dildo dipper
that's a big ass dildo i think i think
you won
i can't think of another one that's
weirder than that one that's not that
bad
i think you beat this article that's
really bad job or bad job we're just
weird joe said in japan uh the
government
uh uh has people that are
yeah that jack people off that are in
the hospital yeah they're nurses
but that feels that to me is more i
don't want to be a nurse because you're
like you're providing some sort of care
like it's a it's an essential need it's
essential need right
for this one it's like you can't even
have work talk
like you know if you're like uh like
you're if you're like an accountant you
come back home you want to talk to your
wife or whatever about what happened at
work
like it's just a backyard barbecue that
the whole neighborhood's there and
you're like oh so what do you do bob
you can't share with their kids you
still can't do that with their kids
either
yeah if you're if you're like a police
officer or you're a firefighter like i
said the cat from a tree
you're talking to a kid that's what dad
did today this one's like hey mommy what
did you do today i was just holding all
these big old penises
that one but jacking someone off i don't
know why i pointed at you well there's
medical terms for that i helped someone
i've have uh
i've provided testicular relief today
yeah releasing pressure
yeah yeah but anyone that has half a
brain is gonna be like oc jackson
i feel like these crazier jobs you have
more interesting stories like you don't
want to hear about some [ __ ] who saved
the cat
i want to hear about the lady who dips
[ __ ]
dude honestly i think we like just
specifically take a party like we have
had a really weird job
jk party's are weird challenges and and
like eating some
weird ass [ __ ] like that was pretty true
because like when we when we meet people
that aren't in the youtube game and like
you know we just have small talk and i'm
like yeah
so what we do is so what we do is
i'm like i don't know how to add where
to start that's like a choice right
it's like you like choose to do that not
necessarily for money it's like you
choose that and then like money is it's
a passion not a job yeah whereas
other instances maybe it's like i'm down
to do this for money
like maria she probably doesn't have too
many sure that's probably not her
passion and then in terms of like family
conversations
let's say everybody already knows that
she does that the next time you're going
to have a family conversation is like i
beat my record today
648 dildo dips yeah wow
do you think they get employee of the
year like you know how they have a
certificate
and then maria that's the [ __ ]
quickest dildo in the west
certificate there's like guinness
guinness world record has to come in and
like
[ __ ] time it officially
yeah there's got to be the same kind of
competitions for dildo dipping yeah
that's awesome that was good scales
right there
i like this yeah to get it and you just
have to go quick she's probably like
thinking how many women like these big
[ __ ] dicks
i think that was the first like five
minutes yeah she's like idiots meal but
then after that she's like whatever
all right so we work hard all right
imagine being
being her husband too where like she's
doing that for eight hours at work right
like oh so was she
when she's thinking about grabbing a
penis her hands are like this they're
like this already and then when he's
like
you're going to jack me off tonight oh
he goes oh yeah and then she goes like
this and she's like
oh the husband's like oh
you never mind my feelings are her
that's like to be the husband of maria
peter gonzalez is her husband
all right so i have here here's a here's
an interesting job
so women in taiwan are now earning up to
about
nine thousand dollars and five hundred
nine thousand five hundred dollars
a month as gaming partners
what does that mean like sit there and
watch your game what
like a cheesecake pretty much like a
cheerleader tired like a cheerleader i'm
down
a massage i'm doing the job right now
yeah so if i was playing games i'm gonna
massage
food i'm not just you know like yeah
massage
sing sing a song for me does she rest
her tits on your neck
yeah is there like a job description
you're just kind of like i know
yes i do okay this is really
that's distracting wow okay i'd want
tits on my neck it's kind of like that
back massage spread too yeah you want
her to have him like that
you want him here that means she's gotta
be really really wide no he wants him
here so it's gotta like
come wide and long when he gets cold i
gotta be his boobs
covers his mansions that's nice
[Laughter]
yeah all i have to do is just this it's
like a scarf titty true
titty yeah all right so this is what a
uh stress balls all right
all right so this is what a uh i'm
toasty
instead of having the two drinks on your
side you just kind of
alright you have beer you throw it away
you get tired from playing you got to
wake yourself up it does
it's like a [ __ ] roller coaster ride
she comes in
all right let's do this that's a
business idea
they're very versatile yeah hanging
boobies hanging boobs
well can you we try that when i'm
editing sure thanks for the idea
i've been hooking them up all day man
all right so a gaming
partner this is what the job description
is all right so
uh providing a variety of additional
services for their gaming clients
accompanying gamers may work part-time
or full-time so it's a part-time or
full-time job
uh profiles list a photo of themselves
many seemingly with filters on their
faces company
accompanied by a description of their
services so what they're talking about
here filters on their faces
is this one i was hoping there was a
next one so there's a i guess there's a
site there's a site
uh as a database for you to shop around
for your uh partner your priming partner
your gaming partner yeah oh so she's
online
you she's never there with you yeah are
they there physically
oh that's just like a whole roster so
she's gonna write a window in your game
just like
yeah maybe it's [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm dead
someone to interact with you but yeah
so it's like a lot of they do have
filters on so like they're they're
definitely
hamming up the the filters and trying to
make them look very very
what if they got like five dudes on
different computers and she's just
saying the same thing
yay
you can make like 50 g's a month then i
know it's like remember that uh hong
kong pokemon go grandpa
who we had like 50 [ __ ] phones and he
was just like
oh there's like a wall of phones damn
you could just be you should just have a
wall of phones
and just pretend like they're all your
boyfriends that's a lot it's a lot of uh
what do you call it like energy yeah the
energy
and like very attentive like oh i can't
i wouldn't be able to do that all right
so
the women's main tasks are taking part
in the game as well as helping gamers
relax during
practice sessions for an extra fee
some offer added services such as
singing a lullaby
for their clients to sleep and then
waking them up
later so their human alarm clocks wow
and it's better
there's a lot of gray area here
absolutely uh competitive income
compared to a regular 905 office job the
flexibility of the work as well as the
potential
potentially high income has resulted in
a increasing number of young women
becoming accompanying
accompanying gamers they just have to be
used to the hours of like 10 p.m to like
5 a.m or something yeah it's just like
you just have to just
dial it over to the late night game
hours yeah this is what gamers are
making accompanying gamers are making
150 taiwan dollars to
uh uh 500 taiwan dollars in hours which
equals
5 usd to 17 us dollars an hour
it's not that much they are paid in half
day weekly or monthly rates
more satisfied clients might also
provide occasional cash gifts
to the company and gamers ensuring that
they will be using the services for a
longer
amount of time so this is yeah this is
kind of like
the webcam culture right this is kind of
like when you twitch or
yeah live streaming except they're not
gaming they're they're watching you game
yeah that's just how big the industry is
going we're just streaming like a it's
like a
leech an algae eater you know but not in
a bad way in a healthful way to the
ecosystem
right right right that's true they suck
a lot i thought they would at least be
there in person
then i'm like okay that's like you're
earning that's an extra fee
maybe after the pandemic this this this
idea can blossom into something
complete double yeah that's true it's
like cheerleading support
yeah exactly uh so a full timer can make
three thousand dollars and four hundred
three thousand four hundred 406 dollars
a month whereas they call and then i
guess i don't know
how you become a video game expert but
there's a term called video game expert
and you can make up to 9 540
maybe they actually play the game too
and they're just
they could give tips i gotta make a
right turn right there that's right oh
that's that's the gift
that's the cash gift that they're able
to give or receive
what giving giving tips or like oh no
like gaming tips oh not money tips but
gaming tips
yeah like if the chick actually knew how
to play then she could kind of be like
his second set of eyes yeah because if
she's into the game and she's watching
so much gameplay from so many other
people like she can also like
help out and be like oh yeah i've seen
this map before you know you just gotta
make a right here and do this and this
or whatever you know
that's true because um because when
i think you know we're playing we're
playing uh crash bandicoot
and then so there would be like these
these certain moves that you have to
make like jump and then get the box and
then oh make sure to go to the right to
avoid this one thing and then whatever
and so like i was i was kind of like
there coaching him and like supporting
him so i could see how
how that works now should have charged
them yeah i know well i do
chores chores got it mopping
filling up the water i thought you
charged them exactly the amount of cost
to chart to wash your car
so it just evened out you wash my car
and i'll watch you please in exchange
do you guys believe in making them just
work without getting paid
for [ __ ] because um i think that's a
good idea
but it sucks it's a balance we looked
into this
because i was looking into it um but
yeah there's
there's like three different ways of
approaching like
money with your kid there's the you're
gonna get
paid no matter what happens once a week
allowance there's the
you're only gonna get paid per task like
if
that was mine whatever you want to do
that's how you're gonna get paid
and then there's the blend of the two
where it's like you get your weekly
allowance but if you wanna get more
money then
you can do extra chores and these chores
have
sounds like real life it's like
commission only salary yeah or
commission or salary plus commission
yeah but also in my
so he's at 10.99 at home or yeah in my
house though
it was like if i tell you to [ __ ] do
it you do it all kick your ass
so i was in north korea yeah cause
you're eating which is why you want
to know you're explaining a fourth
option which is just do the [ __ ] work
there's no money here just do it just
[ __ ] do it yep
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you